le moment est venu de choisir les formes
les couleurs et les dessins qui
constitueront l'élégance sur les plages
dans l'été qui arrive car même réduite
au minimum
c'est encore d'élégance qu'il s'agit
[Musique]
et pas d'élégance avec des gens poilus
mesdames l'arrivée des maillots de bain
et des jupes déclare la guerre aux poils
si ces messieurs le rasoir les femmes
utilisent la plus traditionnelle des
techniques maintenant l'épilation à la
cire est passé dans les moeurs c'est le
seul procédé qui permettent à
dégénérescence progressive du poil qui
s'affaiblit tandis que le rasoir lui
donne de la vigueur
voici notre ami tout heureux du résultat
on leur comprenant dans les années 60
plus question de souffrir pour être
belle grâce à une crème révolutionnaire
la bien nommée crème dépilatoire
garantie en dollars elle dit souvent 10
ou 15 minutes la base des poils
après ce temps il suffit d'ôter la pâte
avec un coton imbibé d'eau chaude ou un
tonique caroline va découvrir des jambes
lisses à la peau satinée agréable au
regard
petit problème siro crème dépilatoire
les poils ça repousse alors au début des
années 80 on s'intéresse à l'épilation
définitive par injection électrique sur
chaque poil et bien c'est très très long
ça il faut que nous le sachions il faut
compter au minimum un an à raison d'une
séance par semaine au moins
et encore si notre pilosité n'est pas
excessive alors je pense que c'est pas
tellement a conseillé patience ce ne
sont que les prémices de cette technique
qui atteindra en 2000 son apogée avec le
début de l'épilation au laser moins
douloureuse mais pas moins coûteuse car
à ce moment là le poil devient l'ennemi
public numéro 1 chez la femme mais une
pression esthétique énorme pour qu'elle
n'ait plus de poils
là c'est un marqueur de la différence
des sexes il faut que les femmes
ressemble absolument pas aux hommes
donc on leur impose de ne pas avoir de
poils alors le pire ce que les femmes
ont intériorisé cette norme là et qu'une
femme qui a des poils est malheureuse
oui mais ce marqueur sexuelle ne sera
que de courte durée
jambes poilues torse velu orthez
ébouriffés trembler car les hommes aussi
optent pour l'épilation fait pile et
mundo à peu près tous les mois et demi
deux mois en fonction de la vitesse de
repousse des poils mais c'est juste
souhaité éthique personnelle
dix sept ans plus tard les hommes c'est
pile toujours met en mouvement féministe
encourage les femmes à afficher leur
pilosité
une idée qui nous trottait dans la tête
depuis longtemps la preuve peut-être
ferions nous mieux de nous accepter tels
que la nature nous a fait
[Musique]